[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing another somewhat scandalous
what if scenario what if severus snape
hogwarts professor former death eater
and secretly good wizard had been harry
potter's biological father
now before you get too hot and bothered
about how this hypothetical theory would
disrupt the harry potter canon let me
first share that not a whole lot would
have been different at least not in the
actual books or movies not the way i see
it anyway so let's dive right in shall
we okay so in order for snape to have
been harry's biological father he of
course would have had to have had a
romantic relationship with lily evans
the future mrs james potter
being that lily and severus were best
friends since childhood this isn't that
far-fetched i mean it happens all the
time
best friends seek comfort in one
another's arms during times of sadness
stress or relationship woes with their
significant others one thing leads to
another they understand each other in
ways only childhood friends could and
before you know it they've fallen into a
clandestine affair so the following is
just one theory on how that scenario may
have played out for severus and lily
james potter and lily evans began dating
in their seventh and final year at
hogwarts after graduation desperately in
love with lily james proposed marriage
at only 18 years of age the two then wed
sometime between 1978
and 1979 before lilly became pregnant in
the fall of 1979 harry james potter was
born the following summer in 1980
seems pretty straightforward doesn't it
so how on earth could snape possibly
gotten involved well think about it this
way for years before lily and james
finally started dating in year 7 lilly
believed james to be an arrogant bully
unlike many of their fellow classmates
she was unimpressed with his quidditch
skills crew of popular friends and
general bravado
add to that that one of james's favorite
targets to pick on as a teen with
severus snape lily's best friend and you
can see why it wasn't exactly love at
first sight for lily when it came to
james potter
so what if after finally giving james a
shot he was romantically interested in
italy for quite a few years before they
got together there were moments when he
still acted like an arrogant fool
moments of stubbornness and
pig-headedness that led to intense
fights between the two perhaps their
moral views although aligned in the
bigger picture like when it came to the
first wizarding war dark magic and
voldemort was still a little off when it
came to certain topics or dare i say
certain wizards it could be argued that
maybe lily even continued to stand up
for severus after graduation despite his
known affiliation with voldemort in the
dark arts this could have led to huge
row between james and lily james arguing
that it was out of the question that
they even mentioned the likes of snape
ever again and lilly defending that most
people have both good and bad inside of
them this particular argument most
certainly wouldn't have gone over very
well
james would have been beside himself
with jealousy and disbelief why would
she defend a known death eater
eventually lily would have had enough
she would have stormed out of their home
in godric's hollow into a dark cold
autumn night and before she knew what
she's doing she would have been
searching for her old best friend
severus she knew who snape truly was and
she would prove james and everyone else
who doubted her wrong now snape having
been in love with lily since he was a
boy may have been keeping an eye out for
her making it not so difficult for her
to find him and find him she did he
comforted her she saw him to be the good
wizard she knew he was
he was so very different from james and
his arrogance and before she realized
what was happening she'd been unfaithful
now it only happened just the once but
once is enough
nine months later on july 31st harry was
born lilly was never 100 certain who
harry's biological father was severus or
james although she would have had her
suspicions and out of guilt she agreed
to name harry after james's grandfather
and to make james his middle name she
may have even thought to herself at
least the boy would be james potter's
son in name if nothing else
of course then the prophecy came out and
voldemort decided he would end harry's
life and the lives of his parents before
the prediction would have a chance to
come true as we see laid out in this
exchange between snape and dumbledore
the the prophecy the prediction trelawny
ah yes how much did you relate to lord
voldemort everything everything i heard
that is why it is for that reason he
thinks it means lily evans the prophecy
did not refer to a woman it spoke of a
boy born at the end of july
you know what i mean he thinks it means
her son he's going to hunt her down
kill them all
if she means so much to you surely lord
voldemort will spare her could you not
ask for mercy for the mother in exchange
for the sun
i have
i have asked him
you disgust me
hide them all then he quote keep her
them safe
please sadly as we know neither snape
nor dumbledore was able to keep lily or
james safe voldemort murdered them both
and snape in his devastation of the loss
of the love of his life once again ran
to dumbledore obviously we all know how
that played out but now you may be
thinking with the timing of harry's
birth wouldn't snape have thought that
harry could have been his wouldn't he
have cared more about young harry if
he'd known he could have been his child
well not necessarily the snape very
easily could have blamed harry for
putting lily in harm's way
after all harry was the reason voldemort
went after the potters to love struck
distraught severus harry was the very
reason he was never able to get his
happy ending with lily because if she
hadn't died maybe she would have found
her way back to him again
and so snape and harry's relationship
would have remained as it was in the
series tense hostile yet somewhat caring
after all snape did indeed look out for
harry on more than one occasion for
example he saved him from professor
quirrell's incantations during a
quidditch match in his first year he
then helped harry learn occlumency to
protect his mind from voldemort he even
discovered that harry was using his old
textbook in the half blood prince yet he
didn't expose harry for pretty much
cheating his way through potions this is
your copy of advanced potion making is
it potter yes said harry still breathing
hard
you're quite sure of that are you potter
yes said harry with a touch more
defiance snape's reaction to
dumbledore's admission that he basically
mentored harry to die also aligned with
him having truly cared for harry i have
spied for you and lied for you put
myself in mortal danger for you
everything was supposed to be to keep
lily potter's son safe now you tell me
you've been raising him like a pig for
slaughter note that snape says lily
potter's son not james i'm just saying
so as you can see as i said earlier
i don't really think a lot would have
changed within the series from the
perspective of the reader in my opinion
there would have only been one scene
that would have been played out
differently when harry watched the
memories that snape gave him right
before he died in the deathly hallows in
this version of snape's memories the
first few would have been the same but
included in the series of flashbacks
would have also been the admission that
lily and snape had had an affair and
that severus had his suspicions that
harry was his biological son
of course this would have been a
mind-blowing revelation but when
compared to the fact that harry also
learned that he must die in order to
defeat voldemort i don't think it would
have been the biggest shock from this
particular trip down memory lane from
there i still think the same witches and
wizards would have appeared when harry
used the resurrection stone after all
james never suspected that he wasn't
harry's father and he loved harry very
much
and as we've covered snape's
relationship with harry was complicated
even the names of harry and ginny's
future children wouldn't have changed as
they named one of their sons albus
severus potter so there you have it if
severus snape had been harry potter's
biological father
not a whole lot would have really
changed about the series what do you
think did you like this what if scenario
or not let me know your thoughts on this
one in the comments below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember after all this time
always
you